bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7 8 l'actu
18h si vous nous suivez en direct dans
un instant je recevrai la baie pierre
Hervé Grosjean prêtre de la paroisse de
Saint-Cyr l'école il est l'auteur de
aimer en vérité aux éditions Arthez on
parle pour l'instant politique pour
débuter ce journal on parle des
européennes Raquel Garrido la numéro 2
de la liste Front de Gauche en
Île-de-France était présente ce midi
devant les portes de l'usine PSA à
Poissy cette proche de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon membre du Parti de Gauche à
exprimé son soutien aux salariés de
l'entreprise une nouvelle fois opposée à
leur direction cette fois-ci ce sont les
primes d'intéressement qui ont mis les
salariés en colère leur montant à l'aide
de 2 euros à 15 euros au milieu des
militants et des salariés à calgarido on
a profité pour lancer sa campagne dans
les Yvelines c'est au micro de Mathieu
bidon et David charpentier
bah justement transformer cette colère
qui est une colère saine dans une action
civique une action citoyenne qui est la
seule façon de prendre du pouvoir quand
on n'a pas de pouvoir économique la
concurrence libre de tout ce contre tous
que ce soit au niveau mondial ou au
niveau européen n'apporte rien de bon et
qu'en réalité il faudrait que dans
chaque pays on produit ce dont on a
besoin chez nous pour nous si l'Europe a
quelque chose à apporter on va dire à
l'humanité comme proposition politique
c'est ça c'est le protectionnisme
solidaire pour mettre en oeuvre un
modèle de société qui soit écologique
qui soit sociale européenne toujours
l'UMP a désigné l'ensemble des candidats
sur ces listes et le maire d'Élancourt
premier vice-président de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
Jean-Michel fourgouse figurant 7e
position en Île-de-France et le
représente donc le département dans ce
scrutin aux côtés également de Cécile
Dumoulin une ancienne députée elle aussi
de la 8e circonscription du département
des Yvelines
elle nous en parlions hier Dany Boon
était présent au golf de
Saint-Nom-la-Bretèche pour un tournoi
caritatif il est le parrain de
l'association mécénage chirurgie
cardiaque retour sur son parcours sur le
green mais aussi sur le travail de cette
association qui permet à des enfants
malades du cœur à l'étranger de venir en
France lorsque les finances et la
technologie manque dans leur pays
d'origine de l’interez et Jonathan
Wilman
Josiane est arrivé en franc il y a une
dizaine de jours cette petite congolaise
âgée de deux ans est venue se faire
opérer d'une malformation cardiaque
chaque année comme elle environ 200
enfants de pays défavorisés viennent se
faire opérer du coeur en France grâce à
l'association Mécénat Chirurgie
Cardiaque alors pourquoi ils peuvent pas
être soignés sur place parce que
manque d'argent
manque de technicité
manque de spécialistes car la chirurgie
cardiaque de l'enfant c'est quand même
une spécialité dans la spécialité
pour donner un coup de pouce à
l'association chaque année un tournoi de
golf solidaire est organisé à ça dans la
Bretèche pour cette 17e édition du
Trophée du coeur Dany Boon a accepté
d'en être le parrain c'est une histoire
de coup de cœur et après de dire et
enfin après je voilà après il faut c'est
là disponible pour pour aider la
situation et mettre man notoriété au
service de
la récolte de fond quoi
lors de ce trophée du coeur les fonds
récoltés vont permettre de sauver 11
enfants pour la prise en charge de
chaque malade mais Sénat chirurgie
cardiaque a besoin de 12000 euros en
moyenne une somme qui serait deux à
trois fois plus élevé sans l'association
et ses familles d'accueil bénévoles
engagés depuis plusieurs années dans
l'association Josiane est déjà le
cinquième enfant que Cécile reçoit chez
elle et à chaque fois le même bonheur on
s'ouvre déjà simplement l'ouverture à
une culture à des pays et un plus petit
qui en a vraiment besoin qui est
condamné s'il reste chez lui donc on
sent franchement on sent utile Josiane
se fera opérer le 13 mai prochain et
retournera chez elle au Congo en 17 ans
l'association a déjà permis à plus de
2200 enfants de se faire opérer du cœur
ce dimanche a été très particulier pour
les catholiques la double canonisation
de Jean-Paul II mais aussi de Jean XXII
cela se passait à Rome plus proche de
nous à Poissy les 800 ans de la
naissance de Saint Louis et qui est né
et qui a été baptisé dans cette ville de
Poissy pour lui rendre hommage le
descendant des rois de France Henri dans
Léon le compte de Paris était présent
Catherine zulato
son illustre Riol semble regarder la
cérémonie avec bienveillance tout un
symbole Henri d'Orléans contre de Paris
aux côtés de la statue de Saint-Louis
qui apparaît une épée plantée au sol
d'abord c'était un roi qui a toujours
exprimé que la justice était la chose la
plus importante mais que la justice
était pas celle d'une classe c'était
celle de l'homme la justice de l'homme
pour lui rendre sa liberté et ça c'est
très très important il a d'ailleurs été
le premier je crois en France à
instaurer les cours d'appel
Saint Louis était également sollicité
par les monarchies d'Europe pour
apporter son regard diplomatique un
rappel historique et une visite qui
n'est pas passée tout à fait inaperçue
l'occasion de demander à se descendant
des rois de France quel est son rôle
dans la société républicaine
d'aujourd'hui une réponse tout en nuance
le véritable rôle que nous avons à jouer
n'est pas un rôle politique
je pense que
l'approche l'écoute des gens est très
important
l'important c'est aussi de pouvoir
apporter
une réflexion une réflexion qui touche à
l'essentiel de la personne humaine
et de son rôle dans la cité
auparavant le comte de Paris et son
épouse ont assisté à une messe en
hommage à lui neuve un roi canonisé en
je reçois à présent l'abbé Pierre Hervé
Gros Jambon bonsoir vous êtes l'auteur
de aimer en vérité c'est aux éditions
artej voici ce recueil qui s'adresse aux
15 22 ans vous êtes le prêtre de la
paroisse de Saint-Cyr-l'École vous
voulez répondre avec ce livre aux idées
reçues sur les relations amoureuses et
la sexualité les a priori de l'église à
ce sujet la banalisation des gestes
amoureux également on va tout de même
commencer par vous présenter vous êtes
un prêtre assez médiatique un prêtre 2.0
connecté présent sur Twitter créateur
d'un blog également vous vous exprimez
avec d'autres sur la culture la
politique sur la foi bien évidemment
pourquoi avez-vous décidé de vous
engager de cette manière de communiquer
autant mais parce que tout simplement
j'essaie de vivre ce que le pape
François nous invite à vivre quand il
invite les chrétiens à aller au
périphérie c'est-à-dire à ne pas se
contenter de rester dans leur sacristie
mais à parler au monde on a un trésor
qui est la foi de l'Église on a un
trésor qui est l'Évangile et on a envie
de transmettre le grand public vous
connaît aussi pour votre engagement
contre le mariage pour tous c'était il y
a un peu plus d'un an au moment de
l'adoption de la loi est-ce que vous
poursuivez aujourd'hui ce combat
d'abord c'était pas un combat contre
c'était avec l'église mais avec aussi
toutes les personnes de bonne volonté
qu'ils soient chrétiens ou autre
religions ou sans religion c'était de
participer à ce débat de société qui
était important on a à prendre notre
place pour partager nos convictions sur
ce qu'est la famille sur le bien de
l'enfant et ses deux toujours de mettre
l'intérêt du plus petit au centre et
c'est pour ça qu'on a pris la parole à
ce moment-là est-ce que vous continuez
encore aujourd'hui à diffuser cette
parole n'ont pas contre peut-être mais
en tout cas pour faire entendre que ça
continuera toujours l'église elle sera
toujours attentive à défendre les droits
des plus petits à défendre les droits
des plus fragiles à interpeller aussi
les consciences c'est son au fond c'est
comme ça qu'elle sert la société c'est
d'éclairer les consciences sur les
grands enjeux qui touchent à la dignité
la personne humaine à la famille au bien
de la société la présence du premier
ministre Manuel Valls à Rome lors des
canonisations de Jean XXII de Jean-Paul
II vous l'avez vécu comment on a parlé
d'un geste notamment pour apaiser
peut-être les catholiques est-ce que
vous vous l'avez perçu comme ça je crois
qu'en tout cas c'était une présence qui
était importante parce que est un
événement planétaire qui avait beaucoup
de sens pour les catholiques qui sont
nombreux en France et je crois que
c'était bien que la France soit là
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il a dit à
travers c'est pas Manuel Valls qui était
là c'était le premier ministre de la
France et quels
pèlerins qui étaient présents l'ont eu
alors ils ont fait ça devant un écran il
y a un écran interposé mais je crois que
c'était pas c'était pas le lieu c'était
le premier ministre de la France qui
était là à travers lui c'est la France
qui était représenté et ça je crois que
c'est important c'est une laïcité
finalement ouverte intelligente qui ne
nie pas les religions mais qui leur
donne la place on en vient à votre livre
il y a eu ce sondage l'an dernier
réalisé par Opinion ouais et avec cette
question diriez-vous que l'on gère de
plus en plus sa vie amoureuse comme une
carrière 58% des 18 24 ans 50% des 25 34
ans ont répondu par l'affirmative ça
vous surprend
je sais pas en tout cas moi je ce que
j'observe c'est que aujourd'hui ce gère
comme une carrière professionnelle c'est
un peu triste de dire ça j'espère que
j'espère que que c'est pas le cas mais
au fond qu'est-ce que je remarque moi
c'est que dans le cœur de tous les
jeunes que je peux rencontrer et je
rencontre beaucoup parce que je suis au
mini lycée parce qu'on prépare des
couples mariage parce que on accompagne
aussi beaucoup de jeunes dans notre
paroisse ou dans les auderies il y a une
un point commun j'ai tous qui soit
chrétien ou non c'est ce désir profond
d'aimer et d'être aimé et ce sentiment
que seul un amour véritable durable
pourra combler voilà et du coup ce que
je trouve génial c'est d'apporter cette
expérience de l'église ça fait 2000 ans
qu'elle accompagne les hommes et les
femmes dans cet apprentissage de l'amour
t'accompagner non pas de choisir à la
place mais d'accompagner d'être à côté
pour là encore éclairer le discernement
de chacun pour donner les critères de ce
discernement pour aider à se poser les
bonnes questions et pour encourager
chacun à construire du vrai et peut-être
être un peu libre par rapport à ce qui
est trop facile vous écr qu'il faut
lever les malentendus le premier
malentendu à lever je vous cite c'est
que le sujet de l'amour et du sexe
l'église elle n'aurait qu'à proposer
qu'une longue liste d'interdit pourtant
on a bien évidemment le sentiment que le
message de l'Église c'est tout d'abord
l'absence ne serait-ce que jusqu'au
mariage et bien voilà c'est une idée
reçue typiquement cette idée reçue c'est
de dire l'église n'aurait que ça à
proposer l'église l'église n'aurait que
des interdits que des lignes rouges à
pas dépassé à proposer or ça c'est
intenable et c'est juste pénible si on
ne comprend pas d'abord quel est le
bonheur que l'Église propose parce que
toutes les exigences qu'on peut avoir et
c'est vrai que l'Église exigeante et
c'est vrai qu'elle est elle exigeante
pour qu'on garde le sens des gestes et
des paroles qu'on pose mais cette
exigence là elle est possible elle est
positive que si elle est au service d'un
bonheur et donc moi l'idée de ce livre
c'est de dire redécouvrez le bonheur
auquel vous êtes appelé pour autant
l'abstinence jusqu'au mariage c'est le
message qui prenait par l'Église
effectivement dans ce sens que l'Église
souhaite que cet acte la relation
sexuelle qui est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
trouve tout son sens dans le cas d'un
engagement pourquoi parce que c'est
l'acte le plus grand que vous pouvez
donner ce que vous pouvez donner de plus
grand c'est vous quand vous vous donnez
totalement et que cela a tout son sort
toute sa vérité aux yeux de l'église
quand c'est vécu dans le cadre d'un
engagement Jean-Paul II avait une phrase
que j'aime beaucoup puisqu'on a vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure des
canalisations de Jean-Paul II il disait
que les gestes de votre corps soit le
langage de votre cœur vous voyez et bien
c'est tous Voilà l'exigence de l'église
vous parlez beaucoup dans ce livre
surtout au début de la sincérité de
l'amour ce que ça signifie d'être
amoureux vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui les
jeunes ne savent plus ce que ça signifie
être amoureux déjà je vais même un peu
plus loin c'est aujourd'hui il suffit
pas d'être sincère parce qu'on peut
sincèrement se planter il faut
redécouvrir le sens véritable des gestes
et des paroles c'est beau de se donner
c'est beau de s'embrasser c'est beau de
se dire je t'aime si c'est vrai si ça
correspond vraiment à ce que je suis
capable de promettre dans mon coeur et
au fond vous voyez on dit souvent que
l'Église aurait du mal avec le sexe avec
les gestes avec elle serait en fait pas
du tout c'est peut-être elle qui croit
le plus et c'est parce qu'elle a envie
que donc ces gestes soient pas banalisés
que ces gestes ne soient pas appauvris
qu'elle essaye d'encourager les gens et
les jeunes en particulier à retrouver la
garder le précieusement le sens de
chaque geste il ne faut pas culpabiliser
il faut accompagner ces jeunes bien sûr
c'est le message que vous souhaitez
faire passer pour autant vous écrivez ce
n'est pas à 25 ans qu'on se prépare au
mariage c'est à 15 ans ce que vous vivez
à 15 ans et plus prépare déjà l'épouse
et l'époux que vous serez à 25 30 ans
vous faites peser un poids très très
lourd sur les actes et les actions de
ces adolescents au contraire je pense
qu'on les encourage plutôt que leur dire
fait pas ça fait pas ça fais attention
on l'a dit mais tu te rends compte tu es
tu es à l'époque des fondations et donc
c'est maintenant que tu peux que tu peux
être exigeant c'est maintenant tu peux
prendre je te demande pas d'y arriver
d'un coup mais je te crois c'est ce que
c'est ça que de l'église l'Église nous
aime assez pour nous croire responsable
et capable du meilleur et capable
d'entendre qu'effectivement à 15 ans à
18 ans à 20 ans ce qu'on vit nous engage
nous marques mais c'est l'expérience
qu'on que tout le monde fait combien je
vois de gens qui sont blessés
parce qu'ils ont été abîmés parce qu'ils
ont pu vivre parfois dans leur jeunesse
donc c'est juste c'est l'expérience qui
parle et au contraire de dire ben
justement plutôt que simplement de te
donner des interdictions qui seront
pénibles au contraire je te
responsabilise et je t'encourage en te
disant que tu es en train de préparer
une joie immense de quel joie veux-tu
être capable demain voilà pour ceux qui
n'arrivent pas à se garder à se
préserver comme vous les encourager à le
faire à travers cet ouvrage quel message
vous leur donnait sur le port du
préservatif par exemple
pour revenir à ce que vous dites le
vous avez tout à l'heure quelque chose
de très juste je cherche pas à
culpabiliser et l'église elle
culpabilise pas elle encourage parce
qu'en même temps d'être exigeante elle
est pleine de miséricorde ça veut dire
que c'est pas une question ce qui est
écrasante c'est tu peux toujours mieux
faire et je vais t'aider et je vais
t'accompagner voyez et au fond nos
jeunes moi je le vois quand je fais des
conférences dans les lycées par exemple
ils sont assaillis d'image ils sont
assaillés de conseils techniques y
compris sa prévention mais c'est pas ça
qu'il demande à l'église et ça ils ont
assez ailleurs ce qu'il demande à
l'église et parlez-nous du fond
parlez-nous du sens de tout ça
apprenez-vous à aimer pas simplement ne
nous dites pas simplement comment il
faut faire etc on a brevé de conseil
technique apprenez-nous à aimer
donnez-nous du sens à tout ça je repose
quand même la question très clairement
sur le port du préservatif pour ceux qui
n'arrivent pas à vous dites le message
c'est pas non plus de dire faut y
arriver tout de suite faut les
accompagner donc au début il n'y arrive
pas quel message vous leur dites si vous
pêchez si vous êtes si vous avez pas
besoin encore une fois le message que
propose l'église un message qui est qui
propose à la liberté de chacun si vous
n'avez pas besoin du feu vert de
l'église pour coucher ensemble vous
n'avez pas besoin non plus de faire de
l'église pour mettre une capote c'est
clair bien sûr qu'il faut être
responsable
mais encore une fois le rôle de l'Église
c'est pas c'est pas de de vous tendre la
voix de préservatif le rôle de l'Église
c'est de vous apprendre à aimer vous
voyez si vous les gens et je crois
vraiment que les gens ils se trompent
parfois les gens n'attendent pas de
l'église qu'elle parle comme la radio
comme pour autant les gens qui viennent
vous voir aussi ont une fois on des
croyances et ils attendent
le mieux c'est ça
maintenant tu vas y aller en progressant
peut-être pas à pas mais le mieux c'est
d'apprendre à aimer et de te donner
justement de façon fidèle d'attendre
d'être prêt pour te donner et donc
d'attendre d'être engagé pour te donner
ça c'est le mieux et je vais t'aider à y
aller si tu veux si tu ne veux pas et si
tu n'es pas prêt à ça et bien fait
autrement et bien sûr comme disait le
pape Benoît XVI le préditif ça mesure
sanitaire d'urgence c'est-à-dire que si
tu es sur des couchers ce soir à droite
à gauche il disait aussi que ça gravé le
problème c'est pas ce qu'il disait
exactement il disait si c'est que ça si
vous mettez toute la prévention
là-dessus ça n'arrange rien et les
chiffres lui donne raison il disait au
contraire le seul player c'est
intéressant le seul pays d'Afrique ou le
sida recul a reculé vraiment c'est
l'Ouganda ou la campagne de
pour se préserver c'est de dire un
abscien toi apprends à te garder te
donne pas trop jeune de sois fidèle soit
fidèle à celle que tu aimes ma solitude
et toi si jamais tu y arrives pas alors
oui mais après préservatif voyez mais je
crois que c'est important les jeunes
attendent de nous qu'on les croit
capables du meilleur et le meilleur
c'est pas juste d'éviter le pire le
meilleur c'est de construire le mieux
merci Pierre Hervé Grosjean la paroisse
de Saint-Cyr-l'École d'être venue sur ce
plateau vous êtes l'auteur de cette
ouvrage et met en vérité on a beaucoup
parlé du préservatif mais les questions
aussi de l'amitié Léa Delon paragraphe
surtout sur l'amitié de l'amitié
forcément des rapports garçons filles
aussi vous parler de la pornographie
tous les sujets sont bien évidemment
abordés merci à vous d'être passé sur ce
plateau le journal revient vendredi 2
mai 18h excellente soirée vous avez
notamment rendez-vous sur tvfils ce soir
avec Aurélia Debussy pour kiosque le
magazine de la culture à vendredi